[Music]
when it comes to RPG Studios Obsidian
Entertainment is among the very best
from Fallout New Vegas and the outer
worlds to Star Wars Knights of the Old
Republic to and pentiment obsidian games
have placed their stamp on the genre
joining us today for a closer look at
about is game director Carrie Patel
Kerry I am so excited to have you here
we just saw this big reveal of a vowed
and there's so many little bits of
information in there that I want to dig
out and pick your brain around but
before we get into all that I'm assuming
that you don't need to have played
pillars one or two to really get into a
vowed you're absolutely right you don't
need to have played pillars one or two
you can come to the world of avowed
fresh we want this to be a welcoming
experience to new players but if you are
a returning fan there are some
recognizable tidbits for people who have
played pillars one or two can you tease
any more of just those General
connections to the universe and no Major
Spoilers of course yeah there are a
couple returning characters that players
might recognize from dead fire in
particular players who have played the
original games will reckon some of the
parts of the world and some of the
factions the adiran Empire plays pretty
heavily into the world of a vowed so all
of that will be familiar to returning
players we do start to see some of that
pillars Universe now in the avowed
setting which is really exciting and
it's looking amazing so far but can you
confirm one thing for me are we still in
aora we're still in aora and
specifically we're in a region called
The Living lands so again returning
pillars fans will recognize the living
lands as this otherworldly Frontier it's
very remote It's relatively unknown it's
this very dramatic landscape full of all
of these different valleys with these
unique biomes and creatures just a
really unique visual perspective and
it's a wonderful Frontier Z Spot that's
set for adventure there's a lot that's
undiscovered and so that's the part of
aora that we're introducing players to
in a vowed and we also see a character
talking to us in the trailer he seems
like he might be a companion because
that would be a very obsidian thing to
do so what's going on with that yes this
is Kai and he is one of the first
companions you meet in the game he said
I'm that's one of the unique species of
the world of aora and Kai is a character
brings a balance of this really
battle-hardened perspective he's seen a
lot he's served as a soldier and a
mercenary but he also has a really
unique sense of humor so he brings the
spirit of levity and camaraderie to the
party as well and as he's talking to us
he's also kind of conveying well he's
straight up saying that he's afraid of
you and your abilities but it's not like
the heroes are the only powerful beings
in this universe so I'm curious what
that means for who we are as the player
character are we a watcher again like in
Pillars one and two or maybe we have
some connections to the spirit realm and
beyond that gives us these terrifying
abilities so you're not a watcher this
time but you do have a unique Soul
connection to the world that gives you a
connection to the living lens and to
some of the more mysterious forces that
work there the player is also being sent
as an Envoy of the adirin Empire and so
they come with both a very mysterious
Aura but also a certain sense of
political urgency Kai also mentions a
plague that's another bit of detail that
we get within the trailer we see a very
concerning growth on a lot of the
creatures in the world what can you tell
us about this plague I can't say too
much just yet except that it is a unique
Soul plague that is devouring the living
lands and part of the player's Mission
and being sent here is to investigate
and try to stop it we also saw a lot of
combat in the trailer and we see dual
wielding pistols we see spells we see
swords we see just a ton of abilities a
lot that actually is really reminiscent
of the pillars Universe too but those
were isometric top-down view games and a
vowed as a first person game so how did
the team approach that same kind of
fantasy combat but in the first person
for about so we wanted to take that same
depth and breadth of play Styles and
combat abilities and player fantasies
where you can play someone who's very
magically attuned more traditional
fighter or Ranger and really invest in
whatever play style is most appealing to
you personally we wanted to take that
depth and breadth and translate it into
a first-person experience where you can
feel the visceral nature of the attacks
feel the dynamism and the momentum of
those attacks as you're executing them
and that means including a range of
options like as you noted dual wielding
pistols which is one of my favorites
because you don't see that often in
fantasy RPGs but also traditional sword
and board a whole host of magical
abilities a lot of things it'll be both
a little bit familiar but hopefully new
to players as well and I've got one more
question for you because I know the
audience is going to want to know this
one but just how big is this game so
it's going to be roughly comparable to
something like Knights of the Old
Republic 2 or the outer worlds it is set
up as a series of interconnected open
zones that players can explore at their
own pace you can invest in discovering
every nook and cranny in the world
discovering every secret finding every
side quest meeting every character or
you can have a much more focused
experience and it's really up to players
and how much time they want to spend in
the living lands but I'm hopeful that
they're going to spend a lot of time
with us once the valve releases well
Count Me In is one of those players
because I definitely want to read and
hear every line of dialogue everything
everyone has to tell me and discover
every inch of the living lands well
thank you again so much for being here
Carrie this has been so insightful and
fun thank you Tina this has been a
pleasure that was just a taste of what
you can expect from Obsidian
Entertainment when a vowed lands next
year on Xbox PC and Game Pass